[Music]  we're going to meet Uganda straw artists  waste piles up in the slums of campana  plastic bags were banned in Uganda two  years ago but millions of drinking  straws are still despondent members of  the kanawa taka women initiatives  connect the straws they wash then this  infected  and flatter them by hand it is hard work  then the women needs to sports to factor  which deleted used to be hostess belts  bags other fashion items  the products are exported to Europe and  the United States 800 people have joined  the initiative countrywide most of them  women everyone benefits the streets are  clean and women from slums can earn an  additional do you like that if you are  also doing your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bit we share your  stories